esta es una de las columnas que
confluyen hacia la plaza de mayo en el
centro de la ciudad de buenos aires en
este tercer día de esta marcha nacional
que ha recorrido varios puntos del país
y que tiene la consigna de por trabajo
por salario contra el hambre y contra la
pobreza una convocatoria aquí de
organizaciones sociales de movimientos
de izquierda bajo el paraguas de la
llamada unidad piquetera el reclamo está
por un lado como como señalaban por
trabajo por alimentos pero también algún
reclamo fuerte de estas organizaciones
de una mayor asistencia social por parte
del estado algo que el gobierno en este
momento tras el acuerdo con el fm y la
búsqueda de reducir el gasto fiscal ha
dicho que no está en condiciones de
hacer que muchas familias millones de
familias reciben en argentina algún tipo
de asistencia del estado y en este
contexto de país en el que se espera que
la inflación pueda rondar el 60 por
ciento anual en 2022 una pobreza que
está por encima del 37% y una situación
empleo que mejoró levemente las últimas
mediciones pero por un desempleo que
ahora están alrededor del 7 por ciento y
que oculta empleo de baja calidad de
empleo en negro y de muy bajos ingresos
decía en este contexto es muy posible
que este tipo de manifestaciones como la
que estamos viendo en este día se sigan
repitiendo a lo largo de los meses